foreign
[Music]
of 2021 Alaska was on the cusp of the
most highly anticipated vaccine launch
in 50 years the coveted vaccine so as
the state began to roll out shots to
senior citizens age 65 and above the
hottest ticket in town was a kova 19
vaccine appointment so when a batch of
appointments would come online those
would be snatched up within hours or
sometimes even minutes and back in those
days everybody needed an online
appointment you couldn't just walk in
and get your covid-19 vaccine
so it's a really exciting time but we
found out pretty quickly that the
website the state was using to get
people signed up was not working well
for senior citizens
it was hiding the appointments and
several pages of results it was made for
healthcare professionals working on
desktop computers but wasn't work for
people on the phones the maps were
distorted it's showing the Sacramento
County Jail instead of the Anchorage
Health Department here
and so we started to hear from senior
citizens that they were struggling that
they were not making it through the
appointment registration process and so
at this really critical juncture the
senior citizens are starting to contact
us and saying that they're some articusp
of actually giving up and at this really
important moment of the pandemic senior
citizens are frustrated the state is
frustrated and I'm frustrated especially
when I learned that there's no changes
and no improvements that could come to
the website anytime soon but I knew that
there must be a way to improve this
website experience and I knew I had to
at least try
so my name is Ben Matheson I work for
the Anchorage Innovation team in
Anchorage Alaska we're a small team
inside city government that uses data
human-centered design and Technology to
solve problems so we try to improve the
lives of residents solve problems with
City departments and save money
so today I'm going to tell you about how
we built a vaccine finder for the state
of Alaska in one week using R and I hope
to show you how R is a great tool for
rapid prototyping and Rapid building of
products and after this I hope that you
can better appreciate how you have the
tools and abilities to really make some
cool custom rapid products and so before
we started building anything we wanted
it to validate there was a problem and
find out exactly what what this problem
was so we got on the phone with senior
citizens as they were trying to sign up
for their vaccines and we found out a
few things one is that they are
struggling through a complex website we
learned that they're struggling with
some pretty complicated health questions
that show up in these vaccine
registration systems and also learning
that the adult children sometimes of
seniors are the ones who are actually
signing up for appointments
and so we tried to narrow the problem a
little bit to you know how could we help
Anchorage senior citizens who want their
vaccine really quickly find that
appointment so that they can get their
vaccine
and so before we started building
anything big we wanted to do a no budget
build an MVP a minimum viable product
so in this case what is the smallest
fastest quickest thing that we can make
that proves that there is value get into
the hands of people and see whether
we're helping the problem or if we need
to go in a totally different direction
and so this was a literally Friday night
project it's Friday night in early
January and I picked up the tools that I
use when I want to make something fast
and easy and maybe not easy but I picked
up D plier I used Stringer and lubridate
and we're trying to capture vaccine
appointments as they come online and as
they disappear and we learned pretty
quickly that there's no there's no API
coming there's no programmatic access to
vaccine appointments in Anchorage so
it's time to scrape so we use our vest
to scrape the vaccine web pages
and anybody who's ever used a web
scraper knows that it's like trying to
create order from chaos you know you
find a div that appears to have the
information that you're looking for you
know it's border gray 200 is the div
that we want here we go grab that div
and um extract the text from it and from
that text we try to turn that into
structured data that uh that serves our
needs so rip it apart mutate modify put
it back together and make structured
data out of this text
so we're scraping we're able to capture
that data but then it's time for a
really quick front end of how do you
discover vaccine appointments and
because this website was a reaction to
an overly complicated website we wanted
to go with something super simple super
fast super lightweight and so I went
with an HTML table so on the left is the
Prototype that came together after a few
hours on a Friday night it's a web
scraping service that scrapes every 60
seconds to try to find those
appointments as they come up as they
disappear and we show those in a really
simple format no filtering no menus no
Maps no anything it's how do you really
quickly find those actual vaccine
appointments and then it's time to test
so we've we've got this very prototype
website and we send it to people who are
working on the vaccine call center it's
a team of about 40 people who spend all
day on the phone with senior citizens
trying to help them sign up for
appointments and they're able to give us
some really good feedback they're able
to see if it's helping
um and it did help they're able to kind
of use it as a power tool this was the
vaccine call Center's power tool that we
we tried out
and then something else happened and
that this website started to be passed
around between people and it's not a
real website it's not a real product but
over the course of a weekend all of a
sudden there's hundreds of people using
this website and signing up for
appointments and we're hearing back and
people are having a good experience so
we know that there's there's something
there
but it turned into an unexpected launch
we've got this product that's this
prototype but the state liked it they
wanted to use it and so we developed a
really quick partnership with the state
health departments the Anchorage health
department and the Emergency Operations
Center
and nobody from Alaska can do a
presentation without a map of Alaska but
I just want to clarify I work for the
city of Anchorage so we're we're the
biggest city in Alaska about 40 of the
state's population but what the state
wants to do is to use this scraping
based vaccine finder for the entire
state so they want to use it in
Fairbanks in Juneau and Ketchikan and
Kodiak and I I'd say that's that's
awesome that's great but we have to we
have to scramble here and so over the
course of the week we cleaned up the
scraper We Made It Real by buying a
domain and about one week later we
launched so we had an Alaska Statewide
vaccine finder tool
it's what I showed before but basically
cleaned up it's appointments that you
can find by location address vaccine
type it's text above you know on the
phone that works well and that's it
that's that's what we generated and
that's what we started using
and so over the course of January and
February we use this for things like
signing up people for these big Mass
vaccination clinics at a basketball
arena or when we launched
drive-through clinics at hockey arenas
we sign people up through this website
so that's a lot of fun and we got some
good feedback people people were able to
use this to connect their appointments
and this tool was doing what we hoped it
was doing
but it wasn't always uh straightforward
it wasn't always easy and things
definitely don't always go according to
plan so on March 9th 2021 we got word
that the governor was going to make a
big announcement Alaska was going to be
the first state in the country to go
fully open for everybody everybody age
16 and above would be able to get their
vaccine appointments so at 4 44 PM I had
to send this message to my boss
the website was down we had some weird
data come across the scraper and at the
moment that we were expecting the
biggest surge in traffic made the
highest amount of Interest over the
course of the entire rollout
um I have to deal with this
but
um I was able to filter it out keep it
online and I was really happy that we
could put this banner up saying
everybody age 16 alert can now get their
vaccine in Alaska so we stayed we stayed
online um
throughout that pretty busy day
and over the course of this project we
didn't have the most stable website we
didn't have the fanciest website we
didn't have the fastest website but our
measure of success was how fast can we
adapt to everything adapt to new
eligibility adapt to new data adapt to
new pharmacies adapt to do requirements
and and that's exactly what we had to do
uh this this vaccine rollout was one
where Alaska was first and we couldn't
copy anybody else we couldn't copy
California or New York or Washington
um but we kind of had to make it up as
we go if we could copy we we would but
we we just couldn't
and some projects the timelines aren't
aren't what you expect so in early
January we heard a really optimistic
timeline that vaccines will be open by
the summer solstice so uh approximately
a six-month rollout of those of vaccines
before they open up but here was March
9th and it's the Iditarod Trail sled dog
race and we've got
um vaccines roll out to everybody so
this this whole project moved even
faster than we ever really had expected
and we rode those waves throughout
January and February as we opened up to
younger people as we opened up to new
eligibility and we got some for Alaska
some major traffic we'd see 20 40 000
pages on a given day and for this
scraping based website that has uh no
backup and no uh no team besides myself
and my boss we got a million page views
we connected the thousands of alaskans
to their appointments and it served as
the you know Alaska Statewide vaccine
finder tool for uh for many months
and on a personal note I got my very
first piece of fan mail for an art
project
and I definitely sent this to my boss as
soon as I got that email
but as we moved from
um out of those really crazy days of the
early pandemic we wanted to turn this
into something more stable I'd spend
enough
time trying to fix a scraper at 9 00 PM
or 6 a.m and one of the big changes was
that we started with one major data
source and that's scraping this system
called prepmod but all of a sudden we
were bringing in all sorts of other data
we've got Pharmacy apis we've got some
open source project that brings in
Pharmacy chains
vaccines.gov came on board and we
accessed some of that CDC data
and then all of a sudden this simple
project turns into kind of a complex
project with six different opportunities
for things to break
and what I was definitely overdue to do
was to turn all these into into modules
so that when something breaks you can
turn it off when something needs to be
troubleshooted you can Target that in
its own individual file in its own
individual function and it made it from
a brittle website into a a less brittle
website
I also tried to bring in more error
handling errors would break the website
in the early days for sure so I brought
in a bunch more try catch statements so
that you can run a statement and if it
successfully executes your data back but
if and when that error comes we can
still return some valid data we can
still keep the rest of the sources
online and we don't we don't break the
system just because
um those errors did come
for automation we really wanted to track
appointments 24 7 because they were
really going fast in those early days
and so we wanted to scrape every single
minute to see how close we could keep up
with vaccine appointments and the way I
did this was with a Heroku our build
pack and a Heroku Cron job where I
basically ran one script every 10
minutes and then in those 10 minutes I
scraped several times so seven or ten
times every 10 minutes we scraped and we
scraped and we scraped and scraped and
about 5 million HTML pages I think we
scraped before we finally moved off of
that that scraper so that prototype
turned into something that that got used
quite a bit
we also had to adapt to the complexity
that came up throughout the process of
this if you may remember there's a lot
of phases there's phase one B tier one
phase one a tier three and we got a lot
of requests to have information like
this on the website and we don't like
too much complexity and we're pretty
militant about having simple information
as much as possible
so the way that we did this on the front
end was we kept the appointments above
the fold as they say so appointments up
high but we radically simplified the
eligibility information and kind of had
it slightly hidden but we kept the scope
of this as narrow as we can to here's
here's where you find your appointments
and then more complexity came in in that
all of a sudden we've got a lot of
vaccine appointments and supplies at a
certain point and it's turning into a
big list that needs some management and
because we don't want to add complicated
menus and we wanted this to work really
well on phones what we did was just
little little HTML buttons that allows
you to search this table for the city or
region and there's a lot of string a lot
of string searching going on in this so
that was our strategy for dealing with
that complexity
so what what have I learned throughout
this experience
um one is that there's a really subtle
power to creating an MVP to creating a
demo
so if we had asked in advance permission
to do this website
um we would have encountered a lot of
reasons to say no it's like what's
what's your budget what's the plan
what's
uh what's your backup plan who's the
staff in charge of this but when you put
something in the hands of people where
they can interact with it and break
through all those barriers there's
really a lot of magic to it and these
prototypes in our case they're not
they're not pretty they're text on a
phone but sometimes a prototype just a
proof of concept can sometimes
below people's minds just enough to
break through and make progress on
projects
there's also some
secret value in building your own data
set
and in this case we were we were kind of
the only people scraping and aggregating
appointments across the state of Alaska
and because we wanted to track how many
appointments there were we had the tools
to do that and I displayed how many
appointments were available at any given
moment throughout the day and this is
basically out of curiosity because we
wanted to see how fast things were going
but at some point we learned that the
State Health Department was actually
watching this number and actually using
that number to make decisions on when
it's time to open up eligibility or when
it's time to make some changes so when
you build that data set sometimes you
have the ability to uh fine find Value
and find unexpected value in places that
you didn't
intend
so R is a great prototyping tool
especially
with all of you who love R and have
spent some time with it
this project was a series of data frames
that basically would be created
updated modified and then destroyed
every every single minute is what we
would do and because I'm comfortable
manipulating data frames that's that's
what I did and it's ultimately this data
frame that took a lot of a lot of work
but that data frame turns into the
product it's the world's simplest
database that is Json or CSV but that
turns into the actual product so if you
have that ability to work fast in R
you're really set up well to create
prototypes
and in some projects
um
if this project had a different timeline
and we knew we had months to to work on
this I may have used something more
traditional like node.js or python or
something more standard to build out a
web service and a website and maybe some
react or something but this is a project
where the timeline was was now and it's
a timeline of the Prototype is now the
product so in those projects where speed
and flexibility matter most I think R is
absolutely your superpower so if you've
put in the Reps and have that ability to
work fast you're in a really great place
to do that if you haven't put in the
Reps you're doing it you're doing it
right now and I think that you all
should appreciate that you have the
skills the abilities and absolutely the
tools to really quickly make custom
software or custom analyzes or models
and your ability to do that fast I think
can sometimes be a huge advantage in
projects
so if a computer is like a bicycle for
the mind I have to think of r as like
the electric cargo bike it's something
where you can help a lot of people you
can do absolutely anything with it and
you can go fast and really have a lot of
fun so thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]